bueno
estamos en el ritmo de un en una mañana
de domingo para poder evitar las
multitudes que se reúnen en frente del
trabajo más famoso de rembrant y
probablemente la pintura más famosa en
todos los países bajos
esta es la ronda de noche de rembrandt
es un retrato en grupo y también es un
tipo de pintura que era muy
característica de la república de los
países bajos en el siglo 17
esta es una pintura sobre un grupo de
milicias de ámsterdam que estaba
destinado a defender la ciudad pero para
el momento en que rembrandt pintó esto
era en gran parte una ceremonia ellos
tomaban parte en procesiones en desfiles
y en festividades relacionadas con la
ciudad y ellos simbolizaba en todo este
orgullo cívico así es como uno tenía que
pagar cuotas con tal de ser miembro y
siempre ser un ciudadano destacado para
ser importante es por eso que aquí
tenemos a un grupo de ciudadanos de
élite de ámsterdam esta obra está
expuesta con otros retratos de grupos de
milicia en esta sala en que estamos
conociendo pero seguramente esta es la
más sobresaliente
a diferencia de otros retratos de grupo
donde generalmente tenemos un cierto
tipo de luz uniforme y un parecido al
tipo de retrato o de fotografías que le
toman a tu grupo de clases en tu escuela
en cambio aquí en la obra de rembrandt
tenemos a un grupo de personas en el
acto de juntarse en torno a una acción
observa como el capitán está dando una
orden militar de reunirse y seguir
adelante a su teniente hay un sentido en
la función del retrato que ha sido
menospreciado rembrandt ha decidido
imponer un tipo de jerarquía las figuras
en otras palabras en los demás retratos
de grupos hay una luz uniforme y una
tensión uniforme cada rostro y
generalmente hay un manejo uniforme en
cada figura ahora cada figura puede
colocarse en primer plano o colocarse en
segundo plano y de hecho eso dependía
del precio que pagaba cada modelo para
tener ese honor pero aquí tenemos dos
hombres en primer plano que claramente
es lo más importante ellos están
inundados con una hermosa luz barroca
que les da ese aire dramático
la mano del capitán arroja una cruda
sombra en el sorprendente uniforme que
usa el teniente es por esto que aquellas
fluctuaciones entre luz y oscuridad
hacen la diferencia con los típicos
retratos de grupo
esta es una pintura barroca no solo en
el manejo de la luz también en la
sensación de lo momentáneo también en el
tipo de composición de las diagonales
que están definidas por las lanzas que
están lanzadas por el estandarte en el
lado superior izquierdo activando así la
escena ahora si vemos la obra de salsa
también nos da la sensación de
informalidad y movimiento lo cual no es
típico en el género de los retratos en
grupo pero rembrandt nos absorbe con una
narrativa por ejemplo podemos ver tres
momentos en el uso de un arma larga a la
izquierda podemos ver un hombre que está
preparando su arma de fuego esta es un
arma precursora del mosquete y del rifle
en el centro puedes ver a alguien cuyas
piernas se están preparando para el
momento del disparo y puedes ver el humo
del cañón lo cual se confunde un poco
con las plumas del sol
el teniente y en el lado derecho tenemos
a alguien soplando el humo de su arma
después de utilizarla los historiadores
del arte creen que estas imágenes son en
cierta forma derivadas de un manual
sobre cómo usar este tipo de arma de
fuego y esto le da un motivo más de
orgullo al grupo de milicia porque ahora
aquí tienen su arma ellos practicaban en
un campo cercano y ahora ellos nos
muestran cómo tirar pero hay mucho más
en juego mira aquí hay un perro ladrando
también alguien que toca los tambores
otro que levanta el estandarte militar y
hay una niña que marcha y de hecho ella
fue un rompecabezas para los
historiadores de arte si tú las miras de
cerca te darás cuenta de que son dos
niñas una detrás de la otra pero hay una
que es más evidente si tú la ves de
cerca observar a su hermoso vestido
ella tiene colgando una gallina muerta
que ha sido colgada boca abajo en su
cinturón con unas garras prominentes
esto hace alusión al nombre de este
particular grupo de milicia
y que imagina este cuarto repleto de
retratos en grupo y debo admitir que
cuando miro a mi alrededor miro a la
pintura de frans hals perfectamente bien
pintada increíblemente informal y
cotidiana pero pese a ello siento que
ese menos de esa obra no sé ni quién sea
la gente retratada puedo imaginarme
detrás de todos ellos e imaginarme a los
ciudadanos de ámsterdam en el siglo 17
imaginar quiénes eran estas personas
pero de alguna manera me siento más
involucrado con la historia en la ronda
de noche si vemos el franz hals podemos
admirar sus pinceladas la innovación de
su composición también la forma en que
toma riesgos en términos del tradicional
retrato de grupo pero rembrandt
trasciende esa categoría de pintura él
logra que nos interesemos por las
figuras incluso si no sabemos su
identidad en la obra de hals no tenemos
mucho movimiento en cambio rembrandt nos
da una lección de caraballo él está
trabajando el aprendizaje del barroco
italiano pero recuerda que estamos
observando esta pintura de manera muy
distinta a alguien que la podía observar
en época de rembrandt ahora por alguna
extraña razón la pintura fue cortada
cuando fue sacada de una sala militar y
podemos ver que no sólo quitaron la
parte de arriba de la obra también su
lado izquierdo algo no muy centrado a la
izquierda tenemos dos figuras que se
pierden también toda aquella parte
superior del arco y algo de la
arquitectura del espacio y ahora la
bandera por ejemplo no estaba en la
parte superior del cuadro así que es un
poco más ilegible para nosotros quitando
el resto del cuadro y también es
importante recordar que la pintura no se
llamaba inicialmente la ronda de noche
era mucho más específica y se refería a
la milicia que estaba representando y
también al capitán ahí dibujado obtuvo
este título que conocemos en el siglo 18
después de que la pintura se había
oscurecido considerablemente y de que no
existía evidencia concisa de que fueron
la imagen durante el día aunque
la obra es obscura las figuras
sobresalen de esta oscuridad en la
tradición derivada de caraballo esto
sale de la tenebrosa tradición del
barroco italiano y también todo el
misterio y el drama que se imparte ahora
si miras cuidadosamente podrás ver un
escudo grande que fue agregado después
de que muchos de estos hombres murieron
para recordar quiénes fueron
cuando miras esta obra pero ahora desde
atrás y vas entrando a esta galería y
ves a toda esta gente parada en frente
de ella la pintura es entonces tan
cotidiana tan natural que percibes a las
personas interactuando con las figuras
del cuadro puedes observar el
majestuosos curso por ejemplo en el arma
que sostiene el teniente la forma en que
se mueve nuestro espacio o el rifle en
manos de la figura de rojo o en la mano
del capitán que se lanza hacia adelante
esto es lo que se conoce como escorzo y
este es curso está siempre que movamos
nuestros ojos a lo largo de todo el
cuadro y es que esto tiene que ver con
la separación
entre cada persona envueltas en lo que
están haciendo y en la forma en que
todos están llamados a una orden es este
el momento de transición
esta es una pintura que nos permite ver
el complejo momento en donde la gente se
está moviendo desde sus pensamientos
individuales hasta una formación ahora
la galería está llena es hora de partir